tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
dio sono miss e vide mi si vedeva
l'ascella sono fa vj oggi siamo in un
video un po particolare anche oramai sto
facendo solo più video particolare
quindi ormai il video particolare il
gameplay è una cosa che mi state
chiedendo di fare da un sacco di tempo e
di fare la top ten dei siti più belli e
con belli intendo inutili al cazzo
abbiamo fatto sta cosa in diretta tv
qualche tempo fa con catena ma se poi tu
punti
il mouse su un punto dello schermo ti
trova una foto di un tizio che indica
esattamente quel punto solo che i
ragazzi farla insieme a voi sarebbe
leggermente diverso vediamo che diavolo
lewisham a tirar fuori di fatto ragazzi
che ci sono tanti ci sono troppi siti
della minkia in giro quindi ragazzi e le
stiamo facendo una top però una top fake
perché alla fine di cerco io prima
vederlo in una casa is it christmas che
significa e natale è no no non è natale
perfetto nel senso che quando ti
colleghi a natale ti dice sì io barba be
mi ritiro mi chiamo melosa giuro che a
natale torno e vedo una stronzata fa
almeno quella voglio vedere se funziona
il miglior posto su internet non vedo
l'ora di vederlo sapevo convinto
chi cazzo è perché c'è un tizio battuto
che mi sta ciao io grazie tanto gentile
vorresti scavi anni fra teme la legge
sull zio sipro basta strusciarti sua
webcam perché è contento ciao zio
ciao ragazzi volete darmi un approccio
anche se bella murate bella anche tua
zia e se non mica facciamo uno alla
volta sentite ragazzi non è che ci avete
una bella [ __ ] con due tette così che ti
abbracciano ci sono sempre ivan jani va
bene
grazie grazie sempre sempre uomini
sempre uomini e no love you no no no no
no no no no sono nove io sono io vado a
[ __ ] questa una [ __ ] questa raffica
non è una figlia però non è neanche un
uomo ragazzi vi prego finalmente che non
sei proprio megan fox
anch'io tesoro tantissimi fan migliore
va bene ogni porta vieni qua che ci
abbracciamo bella l'interno finalmente
grazie dio è la madonna intriso addio
santo non lo voglio va bene sono una
persona felice adesso basta no things
stop me now niente mi fermera cos'è sta
roba su un pendio star istruzioni spazio
per saltare ma cos'è un gioco di a bali
chi qual è il sogno che sta inseguendo
ai wang yu spawn
poche balls vai di ines
ok e che cosa fanno tempo al tempo di
inseguire i tuoi compagni tutti i
giornali va bene va bene ma veramente io
devo devo muovermi così mamma si sente
ci sono le capre ma io chi sono cosa sta
succedendo ma ove che un cassonetto ma
perché è tornata la musica come se
niente fosse ma veramente
vabbè ho soltanto sognato di espellere
nelle poche volte al mio anno non è che
ho detto chissà che cosa
questa vola
[Musica]
ok è finito mi sembra il momento giusto
per passare oltre va bene così cielo
time per tutte le volte che tua mamma ti
ha detto di non giocare con il cibo va
bene credimi a fare sta cosa o lo stesso
godimento del palpare una tetta cioè del
2007 tra l'altro il sito quindi poco c'è
già una storia dietro da quasi dieci
anni al servizio dell'umanità suo sito
ragazzi questo dal dal nome o i.com va
bene said trombone va bene se diavolo
aspettare play va fatta solo questo c'è
proprio un sito c'è proprio un totale di
20 milioni di click sul tasto play off a
agente non so che cazzo fare la propria
vita poi comunque un po la colonna
sonora della mia vita quindi va bene
bomb punto com
pensavo che almeno questo santo iddio
dal nome sembra abbastanza decente
l'avevo proprio intuito zio dice va bene
la patria utili libri il signor a io
credo che nel mondo a questo da un certo
punto in poi c'è stata dopo una mancanza
di farina no allora hanno proprio
iniziato ad utilizzare la cocaina al
posto della farina pian piano la gente
sta uscendo di testa io sono così ma
sono così di mio però la gente secondo
me è un po ci dà dentro col naso poi non
lo so è per carità repubblica del mango
puoi tradurre questa fase che cazzo vuoi
tradurre il mango produzione della
pagina questa pagina è stata tradotta
beh adesso ho capito che un mango prima
non si capiva anche e anche in false per
venirci lasciai della repubblica gaming
merci beaucoup de bellis hmong le tombe
tel
non vi preoccupate ragazzi se non lo
conoscevate suo sito non lo conosceva un
mango io il prossimo ragazzi e dexter
that's the finger
questo è il dito a bello ha così è un
click così diventa un [ __ ]
bellissimo o ragazzi avete un sito da
dedicare alla gente ci vede fa conoscere
se cosa se non il buon fa vj ditemi voi
se questo sito non è meglio di facebook
solo per sta cosa santo dio questo
ragazzi va beh era famoso questo basta
che fa il tipo così perfetto non me lo
ricordavo però così tanto accordi
immaginatevi di essere tipo a scuola
quando vi danno una verifica davanti
guardate le domande e non sapete un
cazzo ciò che succede nel vostro
cervello è esattamente questo
[Musica]
perfetto pointer pointer punto come
bellissimo l'avevo fatto con cutter
hanno appunto ed è stranissimo perché
costo sito se tu vai col cursore su un
punto dello schermo ti compare una foto
di uno che ho una in questo caso che
indica il cursore cioè non è una cosa
normale che tipo se lo sposto qua ditemi
voi se non è la cosa più utile che
abbiate visto in tutta la vostra vita
dopo donald trump
una cosa incredibile e va bene salerno
domanda ma chi è che si è messo a
mettere tutte le foto precise ma che
questo lo puoi stare così male è
addirittura doppio kate bouncing because
this is the internet cat bounce gli atti
che salva make it rain guarda come
rimasto questo gesto gatto ragazzi e
michael jackson la spiegazione del sito
è stupendo cioè tipo gatti che
rimbalzano perché internet è così ma
venga poi il fatto di prendersi un
anguilla in faccia al rallenty è la cosa
più bella di questa vita c'è santo in
dio guarda la smorfia di felicità prima
di ricevere l'anguilla in faccia e poi
magari non è un anguilla però io sono
stupido quindi va bene schifo perche mi
lascia tutta la bava koala sold e max o
ala sud e max dot.com anche figo tu vai
col cursore sui cosi si moltiplicano
figata devo farli diventare tutti i
piccolissimi
oh cazzo ma sta spuntando un koala non
avevo capito sta ma veramente a era già
un senso perché si chiama qua vasto sito
finito ci ho messo due anni per fa sta
roba però perfetto grazie qua la mia
soddisfazione è il primo è ei punto com
io sto applicando un cazzo ragazzo da
solo su mauro land fammi sentire che ci
sei ragazzi simulatori di scoppiettare
le bolle col mouse
manca tutto proprio l'orgasmo ai
presenti l'orgasmo interno che ti arriva
quando premi questi cosi dove cazzo è
non mi dà la stessa soddisfazione ma le
ragazzine che questo è tutto per i siti
più strani che esistano meno male che
avete visto il video perché non avrei
saputo spiegarvela star o comunque sia
ragazzi sono altre robe tipo top schede
sul website che sono i siti più paurosi
addirittura sempre zombo perché tombolo
mettono in mezzo ovunque che fa cagare
fatemi sapere ragazzi se volete altre
top su altri siti tipologie di siti
anche magari facciamo sapere qua sotto
magari non porno perché non si può fare
un mi piace per i 10 miliardi di
abbracci che ho avuto perché santo iddio
perché con tutti questi abbracci ho
guadagnato tanto tanto sudore ma tanto
spero che vi sia per cento ragazzi cose
che piacciono al momento è un mi piace
anche al progetto di facebook come vivi
dato notizia le sale dove si discute ci
vediamo al prossimo video bene ragazzi